Shure:  土豆
Shure: Potato.
Katrina:  土豆侠吃土
Katrina: Potato Knight eats soil.
Lucia: 这还有一个
Lucia: There's another one here.
Shure:  以塔塔ki马斯
Shure: Itadakimasu.
Alice: 他够不到
Alice: He can't reach it.
Alice: 我们挪一下啊
Alice: Let's move it a bit.
Alice: 那边还有一个
Alice: There's another one over there.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  我靠 6张披萨
Shure: Damn, 6 pizzas!
Tasha: 天不是吧
Tasha: No way.
Lucia: 哎哎为什么会是6个披萨呢
Lucia: Hey, why do we have 6 pizzas?
Jake: 买2赠2啊
Jake: Buy 2, get 2 free.
Tasha: 买3赠3
Tasha: Buy 3, get 3 free.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: What?
Alice: 啊现在有那个活动
Alice: Oh, there's a promotion now.
Lucia: 但我们不是买了
Lucia: But we didn't buy...
Lucia: 就是我还以为是我们买4个
Lucia: I thought we bought 4, with 2 of them being free.
Lucia: 其中有两个是送的呢
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Alice: 不行
Alice: Nope.
Alice: 我想在这
Alice: I want to be here.
Katrina:  从未打过这么富裕的仗
Katrina: I've never had such a luxurious meal.
Katrina:  这么多箱子
Katrina: So many boxes.
Jake: 对流水席
Jake: Yeah, it's like a banquet.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina:  哦对
Katrina: Oh yeah.
Katrina:  可以站在这边站着吃吧
Katrina: Can we eat standing here?
Jake: 站着吃吧
Jake: Let's eat standing.
Jake: 要不就
Jake: Or we could...
Katrina:  行啊
Katrina: Sure.
Shure:  要不我们什么击鼓传花停哪就
Shure: How about we play the passing game, and wherever it stops, we eat there?
Shure:  哈哈哈就吃哪啊
Shure: Hahaha, just eat wherever it stops.
Jake: 那你把你的音箱拿上来
Jake: Then bring your speaker.
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: I don't have one.
Jake: 手套可以
Jake: Gloves will do.
Tasha: 谢谢
Tasha: Thanks.
Shure:  没开是吗
Shure: Is it not on?
Katrina:  我说开了
Katrina: I said it's on.
Katrina:  我看有多少电量
Katrina: Let me check the battery.
Katrina:  要不要充一会
Katrina: Do we need to charge it for a bit?
Tasha: 嗯谢谢
Tasha: Hmm, thanks.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  我亮了吗
Katrina: Is it on?
Shure:  你亮着
Shure: It's on.
Katrina:  他怎么肯定
Katrina: How can you be sure?
Katrina:  还挺吓我一跳我们遛一下
Katrina: Gave me a fright, let's take a walk.
Lucia: 三个多余的哈哈哈
Lucia: Three extras, hahaha.
Alice: 可以开始了吗
Alice: Can we start now?
Lucia: 可以尝尝
Lucia: You can try it
Jake: 我先吃也行
Jake: I can eat it first too
Jake: 问题不大问题不大问题不大
Jake: No problem, no problem, no problem
Jake: 一切都充满着变化
Jake: Everything is full of changes
Jake: 哈哈哈问题不大
Jake: Hahaha no problem
Tasha: 早知道点两个榴莲了
Tasha: Should've ordered two durians
Jake: 子涵喝水
Jake: Zihan, drink water
Jake: 你喝哪一个
Jake: Which one are you drinking?
Jake: 几号
Jake: What number?
Katrina:  今天是什么活动
Katrina: What's the event today?
Katrina:  这个怎么会有6个
Katrina: Why are there six of these?
Katrina:  买4赠2
Katrina: Buy four, get two free
Shure:  买一赠一
Shure: Buy one, get one free
Tasha: 买3赠3
Tasha: Buy three, get three free
Tasha: 我刚才想买4个的话是会不会不够
Tasha: I was just thinking if buying four would be enough
Tasha: 他这是九寸的
Tasha: This one's nine inches
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm
Katrina:  连晚饭都解决了
Katrina: It even solves dinner
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay
Jake: 啊也好
Jake: Oh, that's fine too
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm
Shure:  一会自己操作一下
Shure: Try it yourself later
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm
Shure:  嗯呐嗯呐
Shure: Yeah, yeah
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Come on
Jake: 嗯这边都是什么管家代取了
Jake: Um, this side is all managed by the butler
Jake: 就是请我
Jake: Just ask me
Jake: 我让他们取一下吧
Jake: I'll have them get it
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm
Jake: 那我告诉你号码还是什么呀
Jake: Should I tell you the number or what?
Alice: 要榴莲的吗
Alice: Do you want durian?
Jake: 53愈合期
Jake: 53, healing period
Jake: 53还是您
Jake: 53, or you?
Jake: 您要什么呀
Jake: What do you want?
Katrina:  喝了咖啡
Katrina: Had coffee
Jake: 打电话吧
Jake: Call
Katrina:  你的食欲会下降
Katrina: Your appetite will decrease
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 好就是我们其实3031栋
Jake: Okay, so actually we are in building 3031.
Jake: 玉河区31栋
Jake: In Yuhe district, building 31.
Jake: 玉河区31 啊
Jake: Yuhe district, building 31, ah.
Jake: 玉河区31
Jake: Yuhe district, building 31.
Jake: 佑佑的院子
Jake: Youyou's yard.
Jake: 啊可以可以对
Jake: Ah, yes, yes, right.
Jake: 嗯好嘞好嘞谢谢
Jake: Mm, okay, okay, thank you.
Tasha: 饱了保护我自己了
Tasha: I'm full, protecting myself now.
Katrina:  披萨好管饱的
Katrina: Pizza is so filling.
Shure:  感觉吃了一半就已经饱了
Shure: Feels like I was full after half of it.
Tasha: 吃了两片
Tasha: I had two slices.
Katrina:  带出去野餐吧
Katrina: Let's take it out for a picnic.
Tasha: 嗯带出去野餐吧
Tasha: Mm, let's take it out for a picnic.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  走累了搞搞个那野餐
Katrina: When we get tired, we'll have a picnic.
Katrina:  那一坐就开始吃
Katrina: Sit down and start eating.
Katrina:  吃完又走
Katrina: Finish eating and then walk again.
Jake: 吃不完带走
Jake: If we can't finish, take it away.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Tasha: 再去采风是吧
Tasha: And then go for a photo walk, right?
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Jake: 这个应该可以吃完
Jake: We should be able to finish this.
Tasha: 应该可以吃完
Tasha: We should be able to finish it.
Jake: 不是就是今天的时候
Jake: Unlike before, we won't waste it.
Jake: 嗯不会像之前一样丢掉
Jake: Yeah, we won't throw it away like before.
Jake: 丢到第二天就没有用了
Jake: If we throw it away, it will be useless the next day.
Shure:  煤气高钙
Shure: High-calcium gas.
Shure:  不能浪费食物
Shure: We can't waste food.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 瘦了吧唧
Alice: So thin.
Shure:  看我昨天还看的那个梗
Shure: Look at the joke I saw yesterday.
Shure:  然后就是绑着他强制喂他吃榴莲披萨
Shure: Then tying him up and force-feeding him durian pizza. 性别问题
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我还以为是
Lucia: I thought it was
Lucia: 夏威夷披萨呢
Lucia: Hawaiian pizza.
Shure:  差不多
Shure: Almost.
Tasha: 榴莲披萨
Tasha: Durian pizza.
Tasha: 这么好吃
Tasha: This is so delicious.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 就是意大利人看到给披萨上放水果
Lucia: Italians would freak out seeing fruit on pizza.
Lucia: 会非常的崩溃
Lucia: They would be very devastated.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure:  咱们饺子里面放水果给你吃一样
Shure: It's like putting fruit in dumplings for you to eat.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 他们传统披萨上面是不放水果的
Lucia: Their traditional pizzas don't have fruit on them.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Shure:  肉夹馍突然给你加了一个番茄酱
Shure: It's like adding ketchup to a Chinese burger.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 没关系我觉得番茄酱蘸什么都好吃
Tasha: It's fine, I think ketchup goes well with everything.
Lucia: 肉夹馍为什么要放番茄酱
Lucia: Why would you put ketchup on a Chinese burger?
Tasha: 丰富口感吧
Tasha: To enhance the flavor, maybe.
Lucia: 异端
Lucia: Heresy.
Jake: 臊子面放cheese
Jake: Putting cheese on noodle soup.
Lucia: 臊子面放cheese
Lucia: Cheese on noodle soup.
Lucia: 但这我怎么觉得还好
Lucia: Somehow that doesn't sound too bad.
Lucia: 还可以接受
Lucia: I could accept that.
Tasha: 我也可以接受
Tasha: I could accept that too.
Jake: 臊子面放cheese
Jake: Cheese on noodle soup.
Lucia: 还有美国的那种做成甜了的披萨
Lucia: And then there's the sweet pizzas from America.
Lucia: 好像意大利人也会觉得很崩溃
Lucia: Italians would also freak out about that.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 今天还有布朗尼披萨吗
Tasha: Do we have brownie pizza today?
Lucia: 你猜吧哦买噶
Lucia: Guess what, oh my gosh.
Jake: 今晚做一个
Jake: Let's make one tonight.
Tasha: 啊我说达美乐的时候啊
Tasha: I meant from Domino's.
Jake: 真他有啊
Jake: They actually have it.
Tasha: 他有啊
Tasha: They have it?
Lucia: 他有
Lucia: They do.
Jake: 他真的有
Jake: They really do.
Lucia: 达美乐有这个味
Lucia: Domino's has that flavor.
Tasha: 布朗尼的
Tasha: Brownie.
Tasha: 还有各种各样甜的披萨
Tasha: And all kinds of sweet pizzas.
Tasha: 吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Do you eat durian?
Jake: 草本草本谢谢您
Jake: Herbal, herbal, thank you.
Shure:  你好像触发了什么
Shure: Seems like you triggered something.
Shure:  NPC对话
Shure: An NPC dialogue.
Jake: 去去去
Jake: Go, go, go.
Shure:  稍等稍等
Shure: Wait a sec, wait a sec.
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you.
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because...
Tasha: 他是那天唯一一个点那个榴莲汉堡的
Tasha: He was the only one who ordered the durian burger that day.
Tasha: 跟我一起
Tasha: With me.
Jake: 一些珍贵的人类吃披萨镜头
Jake: Some precious footage of humans eating pizza.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: My...
Lucia: 眼镜怎么这两天又开始疯狂的往下滑
Lucia: Why have my glasses been slipping down like crazy these past two days?
Jake: 这两天瘦了
Jake: You've lost weight these past two days.
Shure:  真的吗
Shure: Really?
Lucia: 不能吧
Lucia: No way.
Shure:  这都吃瘦了
Shure: You lost weight from all this eating.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 吃瘦了
Jake: Lost weight from eating.
Jake: 太辛苦了
Jake: It's too hard.
Jake: 剧组太辛苦了
Jake: The crew has it too hard.
Shure:  天哪
Shure: Oh my.
Shure:  我们这剧组
Shure: Our crew...
Jake: 把人这两天把人吃瘦了
Jake: Made people lose weight from eating these past two days.
Lucia: 哈哈不至于吧
Lucia: Haha, it's not that bad, right?
Shure:  供吃供住
Shure: Providing food and accommodation.
Tasha: 能不瘦吗哈哈哈
Tasha: How could you not lose weight? Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Jake: 这个有问题
Jake: There's a problem with this.
Tasha: 你看
Tasha: Look.
Jake: 我记一下
Jake: I'll make a note of it.
Tasha: 大家只能挤着一起吃披萨
Tasha: Everyone has to squeeze together to eat pizza.
Tasha: 而不是一个人娱乐
Tasha: Instead of enjoying it alone.
Shure:  就是
Shure: Exactly.
Tasha: 就已经已经遭受不公平的待遇了
Tasha: We've already suffered unfair treatment.
Jake: 不是就
Jake: No, it's just...
Shure:  这段数据要删掉
Shure: This part needs to be deleted.
Jake: 对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 小心小心你这个
Jake: Be careful with that.
Jake: 增加我们很多工作量啊
Jake: You're increasing our workload a lot.
Shure:  对不起对不起
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
Jake: 我要记一下
Jake: I need to make a note.
Lucia: 啊什么要删掉
Lucia: Ah, what needs to be deleted?
Lucia: 吃披萨吗
Lucia: Eating pizza?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Tasha: 12.09
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 受了不公平的待遇
Tasha: Treated unfairly.
Shure:  你看你又说了一遍
Shure: See, you said it again.
Shure:  他又在说
Shure: He's saying it again.
Shure:  多逼逼一句
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 就这这逼逼逼逼逼的
Jake: Just keep on complaining.
Jake: 你们继续吃你们的
Jake: You guys keep eating.
Jake: 但是边吃边逼逼逼
Jake: But keep on complaining while eating.
Lucia: 那
Lucia: Then...
Lucia: 我们之前出现了多少要被道德词汇
Lucia: How many moral words have we used before?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: F word的是不是也要
Lucia: Does the F word also...
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina:  昨天还看到直升机了
Katrina: We saw a helicopter yesterday.
Shure:  啊对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  军用的
Katrina: It was military.
Lucia: 对军用的是不是会侵占他的版权啊
Lucia: So, would the military one infringe on his copyright?
Shure:  看一眼
Shure: Let's check.
Tasha: 我们昨天放的电影
Tasha: The movie we watched yesterday.
Tasha: 要不要删掉
Tasha: Should we delete it?
Lucia: 我忘了
Lucia: I forgot.
Shure:  咱们昨天吃火锅没戴眼镜
Shure: We ate hotpot yesterday without wearing glasses.
Katrina:  哦空调遥控器呢
Katrina: Oh, where's the air conditioner remote?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  不想看来着
Katrina: Didn't really want to see it.
Alice: 呵呵
Alice: Hehe.
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina:  薇薇
Katrina: Tasha.
Katrina:  昨天那个空调遥控器是不是在你那
Katrina: Was the air conditioner remote with you yesterday?
Katrina:  薇薇嗯遥控器
Katrina: Tasha, yeah, the remote.
Tasha: 不在我那
Tasha: It's not with me.
Tasha: 我说放在外面的桌上了
Tasha: I said it's on the table outside.
Shure:  空调遥控器
Shure: The air conditioner remote.
Katrina:  2楼不通风有点热
Katrina: The second floor isn't ventilated, it's a bit hot.
Katrina:  在这里
Katrina: It's right here.
Lucia: 这俩是同一个味吗
Lucia: Do these two taste the same?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 可能你加了之后
Tasha: Maybe after you added it,
Tasha: 我又不小心又加了一遍
Tasha: I accidentally added it again.
Lucia: 不不不
Lucia: No, no, no.
Lucia: 有哪位宝宝需要餐巾纸吗
Lucia: Does anyone need a napkin?
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh...
Lucia: 需要吗
Lucia: Do you need one?
Tasha: 等一下就需要
Tasha: I'll need one in a minute.
Lucia: 那我先放在你这里
Lucia: Then I'll put it here for you.
Tasha: 哦我这怎么了
Tasha: Oh, what's wrong with me?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  哦不
Shure: Oh no.
Alice: 下雪了
Alice: It's snowing.
Tasha: 大家够用吗
Tasha: Does everyone have enough?
Lucia: 要
Lucia: I need one.
Jake: 谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thanks, thanks.
Shure:  张万森下雪了
Shure: Zhang Wansen, it's snowing.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  我再来一张吧
Katrina: I'll take another one.
Lucia: 如果谁需要纸可以传递一下
Lucia: If anyone needs a napkin, just pass it around.
Shure:  是带那个
Shure: Is it the one with...
Shure:  洗洁精的湿巾是吗
Shure: The wet wipe with dishwashing liquid?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure:  哈哈我擦擦
Shure: Haha, let me wipe it.
Alice: 对了
Alice: By the way...
Shure:  怎么感觉味不对
Shure: Why does it smell different?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈再舔起泡了
Katrina: Hahaha, you licked the soap.
Lucia: 哎什么东西
Lucia: Hey, what is it?
Lucia: 带洗洁精
Lucia: With dishwashing liquid?
Alice: 那个厨房湿巾
Alice: The kitchen wet wipes.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 咂嘴
Alice: Yuck.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice: 一个宝贵的数据
Alice: A precious piece of data
Shure:  哎我记得我刚才掉了一块肉在这
Shure: Hey, I remember I just dropped a piece of meat here
Shure:  怎么找不到了
Shure: How come I can't find it
Jake: 掉什么了
Jake: What did you drop
Jake: 掉披萨了啊
Jake: Dropped a pizza?
Shure:  啊不是那个有一块
Shure: No, it was a piece of meat
Shure:  刚才掉了一块肉
Shure: I just dropped a piece of meat
Shure:  我记得掉地下了
Shure: I remember it fell on the floor
Shure:  掉下找不到了
Shure: Can't find it now
Shure:  行了留给蟑螂先生了
Shure: Alright, leaving it for Mr. Cockroach
Lucia: 为什么你们
Lucia: Why do you guys
Tasha: 每个盘都送的好均匀啊
Tasha: Every plate is so evenly distributed
Shure:  一两个两个两个
Shure: One or two, two each
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one
Katrina:  他俩不是一个
Katrina: Those two are not the same
Alice: 所以这个是
Alice: So, this one is
Katrina:  我要问一下他是讲新课还是讲复习课
Katrina: I need to ask him if it's a new lesson or a review lesson
Katrina:  这个得等他回来才知道
Katrina: We have to wait for him to come back to know
Tasha: 要不要把整盒整盒
Tasha: Should we put the whole boxes together
Jake: 好啊拼一拼
Jake: Sure, let's combine them
Tasha: 这俩可以直接拼过来了
Tasha: These two can be combined directly
Tasha: 把这个拼在一起
Tasha: Put this together
Tasha: 对这好像就差两块
Tasha: Yeah, it seems like we're just short two pieces
Alice: 一家子一家子
Alice: A whole family, a whole family
Jake: 这就是什么什么
Jake: So, this is what... what
Jake: 油泼面拌臊子面
Jake: Oil-splashed noodles with minced meat noodles
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Lucia: 必胜客经典二合一
Lucia: Pizza Hut classic two-in-one
Jake: 这二合一确实很好
Jake: This two-in-one is really good
Lucia: 不行我现在站不起来了哈哈
Lucia: I can't get up now, haha
Lucia: 啊谢谢谢谢好了
Lucia: Ah, thank you, thank you, it's fine now
Jake: 嗯挺好
Jake: Mm, pretty good
Tasha: 还好把榴莲的都吃完了
Tasha: Good thing we finished all the durian
Tasha: 不然他会污染别的味道
Tasha: Otherwise, it would contaminate other flavors
Lucia: 好热好热
Lucia: So hot, so hot
Jake: 榴莲还是可以吃完的怎么了
Jake: Durian is still edible, what's the problem
Jake: 哦好热
Jake: Oh, so hot
Lucia: 可能是二楼没有那么透气的
Lucia: Maybe the second floor is not as well-ventilated
Lucia: 稍等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Lucia: 对只有只有卧室的窗户好像能打开
Lucia: Yeah, it seems like only the bedroom window can be opened.
Lucia: 大厅的都打不开
Lucia: The ones in the hall can't be opened.
Alice: 想用一下
Alice: Want to use it.
Jake: 好收溜
Jake: Okay, got it.
Jake: 收丢上礼物上链接
Jake: Got it, let's link the gifts.
Lucia: 这俩叠一块吧
Lucia: Let's stack these two together.
Shure:  这个改过的
Shure: This has been modified.
Shure:  结构大概是这个样子
Shure: The structure is roughly like this.
Lucia: 我们的垃圾袋啊在那边
Lucia: Our trash bags are over there.
Lucia: good
Lucia: Good.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  good
Katrina: Good.
Lucia: 等等我
Lucia: Wait for me.
Lucia: 好像已经好几天没有打卡
Lucia: Seems like I haven't checked in for several days.
Lucia: 我的duolingo了
Lucia: On my Duolingo.
Jake: 学学什么呢
Jake: What are you learning?
Lucia: 德语
Lucia: German.
Jake: 德语
Jake: German.
Jake: 学德语干啥
Jake: Why are you learning German?
Lucia: 比较喜欢哦
Lucia: I kind of like it.
Shure:  想带上我的一切
Shure: Want to take everything with me.
Shure:  然后
Shure: And then.
Shure:  这是水是吧
Shure: Is this water?
Shure:  20
Shure: 20.
Shure:  不能
Shure: Can't.
Alice: 还有纸吗
Alice: Is there any more paper?
Shure:  逼着我喝水
Shure: Forcing me to drink water.
Alice: 啊谢谢
Alice: Ah, thanks.
Alice: 我上个厕所
Alice: I'm going to the bathroom.
Jake: 这个空了
Jake: This one's empty.
Alice: 眼镜
Alice: Glasses.
Jake: duo lin go是不是你很久没上
Jake: If you haven't logged into Duolingo for a long time,
Jake: 他就会把图标变得很丑
Jake: It will make the icon look ugly.
Lucia: 呃对
Lucia: Uh, yeah.
Jake: 就是就真的会很就变
Jake: It will really change, will it change for you?
Jake: 会变吗你变了吗
Jake: Has it changed?
Lucia: 会变
Lucia: It will change.
Lucia: 就是如果说你好好久不去上课的话
Lucia: If you don't attend classes for a long time,
Lucia: 他就会变成要么在睡觉的表情
Lucia: It will change to a sleeping face or something.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 要么就变成沙漠里的一个鸟骷髅
Lucia: Or it'll turn into a bird skeleton in the desert.
Jake: OK
Lucia: 然后如果你每天打卡的话
Lucia: And if you check in every day,
Lucia: 他就会非常开心
Lucia: It will be very happy.
Lucia: 那个表情
Lucia: The expression
Lucia: 如果你某一天当天没有打卡
Lucia: But if you miss a day,
Lucia: 他就会就是呈现一个怒火的表情哦
Lucia: It will show an angry expression.
Lucia: 真的很有意思
Lucia: It's really interesting.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes
Shure:  这是真没有
Shure: That's truly unique.
Lucia: 我觉得我最大的乐趣不来自于学语言
Lucia: I think my biggest joy doesn't come from learning the language.
Lucia: 来自于观赏他
Lucia: It comes from watching it.
Lucia: 这个图标射程
Lucia: The icon range.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Cool.
Jake: 嗯管家什么时候
Jake: Hmm, when will the butler
Jake: 我也不知道管家什么时候
Jake: I don't know when the butler
Jake: 要来收
Jake: Will come to collect.
Jake: 大伙看看自己眼镜还有多少电
Jake: Everyone check how much battery your glasses have left.
Jake: 要不要插充电宝
Jake: Do you need to plug in a power bank?
Jake: 时间差不多了
Jake: It's almost time.
Shure:  一直在挂着尿袋
Shure: Been wearing a urine bag all the time.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure:  我们吃了4个披萨
Shure: We ate 4 pizzas.
Shure:  相当于是吧
Shure: That's about right, isn't it?
Shure:  对吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Shure:  7个人4个披萨
Shure: 7 people, 4 pizzas.
Lucia: 4624
Lucia: 28 大概每个人吃了三四块的样子
Lucia: 28, so each person ate about 3-4 slices.
Lucia: 为什么要算
Lucia: Why calculate?
Lucia: 条件反射的算一下
Lucia: Reflexively did the math.
Lucia: 估算一下大家的饭量以后好点
Lucia: To estimate everyone's appetite for the future.
Shure:  之前还看过一个披萨笑话是
Shure: I once heard a pizza joke,
Shure:  说披萨是最诚实的食物
Shure: It said pizza is the most honest food.
Shure:  因为他没有欺骗
Shure: Because it doesn't deceive.
Lucia: 哦哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 对不会
Lucia: Right, it doesn't.
Lucia: 天呐谐音梗扣分哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my gosh, a pun, minus points, haha.
Lucia: 没有反应过来
Lucia: Didn't catch that.
Lucia: 这个我们要放冰箱或者怎么样吗
Lucia: Should we put this in the fridge or something?
Lucia: 还是就在外面放着就行
Lucia: Or can we just leave it out?
Lucia: 如果一会就用来picknick了
Lucia: If we're going to use it for a picnic soon.
Shure:  先不用放冰箱了
Shure: No need to put it in the fridge.
Alice: 不用放了下午不就拿走了
Alice: No need, we'll just take it in the afternoon.
Jake: 放这吧
Jake: Just leave it here.
Shure:  阴凉遮光无光处对
Shure: In a cool, shaded place without light, right.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 嗯好再打一下我们又可以吃了
Lucia: Okay, let's have another round and we can eat again.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice: 这个是多出来的
Alice: This is the extra one.
Alice: 要搁那吗
Alice: Should we put it there?
Tasha: 嗯这两次尝尝价格不一样人家会说吧
Tasha: Hmm, the price might be different if they try it twice, right?
Shure:  是的哈哈哈
Shure: Yes, hahaha.
Tasha: 不知道呀而且跟你刚刚的界面一模一样
Tasha: I don't know, and it looks exactly like the interface you just saw.
Jake: 子豪我们再看一下充电宝吧
Jake: Zihou, let's check the power bank again.
Jake: 对你你查
Jake: Yeah, you check.
Tasha: 所以要不还是你查吧
Tasha: So, why don't you check it then?
Jake: 再看一下
Jake: Let's check it again.
Tasha: 我真的已经打开了
Tasha: I really already opened it.
Shure:  这是重要素材
Shure: This is important material.
Shure:  所以不可丢不可遗失
Shure: So it can't be lost or misplaced.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 对他要在下午2点钟之前要 我们查完之后看
Tasha: Yes, he needs it before 2 PM. We'll check it after that.
Alice: 你们有空调遥控器在房间里吗
Alice: Do you have the air conditioner remote in your room?
Alice: Lucy
Alice: Lucia.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm?
Alice: 你的那个空调遥控器是在你房间吗
Alice: Is the air conditioner remote in your room?
Lucia: 啊我没注意
Lucia: Oh, I didn't notice.
Lucia: 因为一直没在
Lucia: Because I haven't been there.
Lucia: 在这个外面
Lucia: It's outside.
Alice: 你的呢
Alice: What about yours?
Shure:  我的不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure:  我的还开着呢
Shure: Mine is still on.
Lucia: 你不冷吗
Lucia: Aren't you cold?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  他不
Shure: No, it's not.
Shure:  他是完全自动
Shure: It's fully automatic.
Shure:  就是冷了
Shure: Just cold.
Shure:  他会给我吹热风然后温度合适
Shure: He'll blow warm air at me, and the temperature will be just right.
Shure:  他不吹风
Shure: It doesn't blow air.
Alice: 我觉得你像个面团子
Alice: I think you look like a dough ball.
Lucia: interesting
Lucia: Interesting.
Shure:  为什么
Shure: Why?
Alice: 水多加面
Alice: More water, add flour.
Alice: 面多加水
Alice: More flour, add water.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  昨天和麻酱也是
Shure: Same thing with the sesame paste yesterday.
Shure:  水多加面
Shure: More water, add flour.
Shure:  水多加麻酱
Shure: More water, add sesame paste.
Shure:  麻酱多加水
Shure: More sesame paste, add water.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 怪不得你最后和出那么大一碗来
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  肯定都和上
Shure: It all mixed in for sure.
Lucia: 我的东西在京东上找不到怎么办呢
Lucia: What if I can't find my stuff on JD?
Lucia: 淘宝
Lucia: Taobao.
Alice: 我都是淘宝
Alice: I always use Taobao.
Lucia: 我怕淘宝他到不了
Lucia: I'm afraid Taobao won't deliver.
Alice: 到不了我就退了
Alice: If it doesn't deliver, I just return it.
Lucia: 哈哈有道理啊
Lucia: Haha, makes sense.
Alice: 我一般就是他那种呃
Alice: I usually go for the ones that ship within 24 or 48 hours.
Alice: 48小时24小时之内发货的
Alice: Then I buy it.
Alice: 我就买了
Alice: If it can't be delivered, I return it.
Alice: 买不到到不了就退了
Alice: Simple as that.
Lucia: 要不因为我在淘宝上看到了
Lucia: Well, I saw my fishing nets on Taobao.
Lucia: 我的那些渔网什么的
Lucia: They look pretty good.
Lucia: 我觉得还挺合适的
Lucia: I think I'll just buy them there.
Lucia: 那我还是淘宝上买算了
Lucia: It's for decorating my room.
Alice: 呃
Alice: Uh.
Lucia: 这是用来装饰房间的
Lucia: It's for decorating my room.
Shure:  渔网
Shure: Fishing nets?
Katrina:  捕梦网是不是
Katrina: Dreamcatchers, right?
Lucia: 哦没有就是
Lucia: Oh no, it's just...
Lucia: 是对但是跟海有关
Lucia: Yes, but related to the sea.
Lucia: 就我想的是
Lucia: So I was thinking...
Lucia: 可能做成地中海风格的那种
Lucia: Maybe a Mediterranean style.
Lucia: 蓝白的颜色
Lucia: Blue and white colors.
Lucia: 但我发现我现在买的材料都是白的
Lucia: But I realized all the materials I bought are white.
Lucia: 还没有蓝材料呢
Lucia: We still don't have the blue material.
Alice: 如果你想做地中海风格
Alice: If you want to go for a Mediterranean style,
Alice: 我可以把高中的老师捐给你
Alice: I can donate my high school teacher to you.
Lucia: 把高中老师捐给我
Lucia: Donate your high school teacher to me?
Lucia: 为什么
Lucia: Why?
Alice: 因为他是个地中海啊
Alice: Because he's balding like the Mediterranean.
Lucia: 啊OK好
Lucia: Oh, okay, got it.
Jake: 那我再说
Jake: Let me say something.
Jake: 你还有电吗
Jake: Do you still have battery?
Alice: 露西呀你还有电吗
Alice: Lucia, do you still have battery?
Lucia: 嗯你在问我吗
Lucia: Huh, are you asking me?
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Tasha: 这个在录着呢
Tasha: This is recording.
Jake: 你你你插掉
Jake: You, you, you unplug it.
Tasha: 直接插掉就行吗
Tasha: Just unplug it?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 还有60%
Tasha: It's still 60%.
Jake: 嗯行可以
Jake: Yeah, that's fine.
Shure:  你看那个磁吸压到头发了
Shure: Look, the magnet is pulling on your hair.
Lucia: 我打算把那个串珠还是买一串
Lucia: I plan to buy another string of beads.
Lucia: 好吧如果他来得及到
Lucia: Well, if it arrives in time.
Lucia: 咱可能还能做一下那个水母灯
Lucia: Maybe we can make that jellyfish lamp.
Lucia: 再来点欧根纱
Lucia: Let's get some more organza.
Alice: 我本来昨天想买的
Alice: I wanted to buy it yesterday.
Alice: 然后发现跟我的啊
Alice: Then I realized it didn't match mine.
Lucia: 啊我打算买一米的蓝色欧根纱
Lucia: Oh, I plan to buy a meter of blue organza.
Lucia: 我可以在房间里面弄一下
Lucia: I can use it in my room.
Lucia: 然后剩下的就你如如果就算真的要做灯
Lucia: And if there's any left, we can use it for the lamp.
Lucia: 它里面用的纱也很少
Lucia: The lamp doesn't need much fabric.
Lucia: 就我们每个人可以弄一块
Lucia: We can each have a piece.
Lucia: 然后放在里面
Lucia: And put it inside.
Alice: 然后给他剪掉
Alice: Then cut it.
Lucia: 对对就比较好看一些
Lucia: Yeah, it will look better.
Alice: 边角料可以旋转一下固定一下
Alice: The scraps can be twisted and fixed.
Alice: 然后贴贴
Alice: Then stick them.
Alice: 贴在什么地方
Alice: Stick them somewhere.
Lucia: 对的
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 我觉得你昨天安利给我的那个桌布
Lucia: I think the tablecloth you recommended yesterday
Lucia: 真的很好看
Lucia: is really nice.
Alice: 嗯我也我也买桌布了
Alice: Yeah, I bought a tablecloth too.
Jake: 桌布桌布挂墙上
Jake: Tablecloth, tablecloth, hang it on the wall.
Lucia: 不是啦
Lucia: No, that's not right.
Lucia: 桌布当然是放在桌子上
Lucia: A tablecloth should go on the table, of course.
Jake: 你们有桌子吗
Jake: Do you guys have a table?
Alice: 我有一个小的
Alice: I have a small one.
Lucia: 他有小桌子
Lucia: He has a small table.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 四十乘
Alice: It's like 40 by...
Lucia: 我打算配一个塑料的小方桌
Lucia: I'm planning to get a small plastic table.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 就会能轻一点
Lucia: So it would be lighter.
Lucia: 也不是很贵
Lucia: And not very expensive.
Lucia: 因为我那个架子实在是太丑了
Lucia: Because my current stand is really ugly.
Jake: 明白
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 无法改造我觉得
Lucia: I think it's impossible to modify it.
Alice: 我觉得我们这个户型还挺好的
Alice: I think our layout is pretty nice.
Alice: 因为比较小就
Alice: Because it's quite small...
Shure:  往下东西
Shure: Things tend to fall down.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Alice: 哎东西呢
Alice: Hey, where's the stuff?
Jake: 我们也整点喝的吧
Jake: Let's get something to drink.
Jake: 哈哈给给您倒点咖咖啡给您倒点水
Jake: Haha, I'll pour you some coffee, or maybe some water.
Shure:  谢谢
Shure: Thanks.
Katrina:  这咖啡吗
Katrina: Is this coffee?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  这好像昨天晚上调的
Katrina: It looks like it was made last night.
Jake: 就是这个
Jake: Yeah, it is.
Jake: 这些应该都用过
Jake: These should all be used.
Jake: 来吧我们
Jake: Come on, let's...
Jake: 我们最后一名做到
Jake: We'll have the last one do it.
Katrina:  我怎么做到老板
Katrina: How do I do it, boss?
Alice: 最后一名
Alice: The last one?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 我也不做
Jake: I won't do it either.
Jake: 就是呃我们最后一名开始
Jake: It's just, um, we'll have the last one start.
Jake: 呃介绍自己的礼物然后第一名
Jake: Uh, introduce their gift, and then the first one...
Jake: 呃大家秀一轮之后然后第一名开始挑
Jake: Uh, after everyone shows theirs, then the first one gets to choose.
Jake: 对对对我们排名了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, we've ranked them.
Lucia: 我以为是盲挑呢
Lucia: I thought it was a blind pick.
Alice: 到1-2
Alice: Up to 1-2.
Alice: 嗯我在你后边
Alice: Hmm, I'm behind you.
Tasha: 呃我不知道
Tasha: Uh, I don't know.
Tasha: 写了一个东西
Tasha: I wrote something.
Tasha: 乱七八糟的东西
Tasha: A bunch of random stuff.
Jake: 笑口常开
Jake: Keep smiling.
Tasha: 明信片
Tasha: Postcard.
Shure:  天下粮仓
Shure: Granary of the world.
Tasha: 种植套餐
Tasha: Planting package.
Katrina:  呵呵呵
Katrina: Hehehe.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Lucia: 这是装什么呀
Lucia: What's this for?
Tasha: 营养塔
Tasha: Nutrition tower.
Tasha: 营养土盆栽和培养米种这张卡片的
Tasha: Nutrient soil, potted plants, and the rice seeds on this card.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Shure:  这鼓好用吗
Shure: Does this drum work well?
Katrina:  把这摆着
Katrina: Put this here.
Jake: 不要太玩
Jake: Don't play around too much.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Lucia: 你说这个鼓吗
Lucia: You mean this drum?
Katrina:  不是  蛊  虫子下蛊了
Katrina: No, it's a Gu, a curse with insects.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
Shure:  这个怎么翻译成英文
Shure: How do you translate this into English?
Katrina:  100人就开始算塔罗了
Katrina: With 100 people, we start reading tarot.
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Tasha: 营养土啊
Tasha: Nutrient soil.
Lucia: 是椰土那种吗
Lucia: Is it the coconut soil type?
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 香菇是长
Jake: Mushrooms grow.
Jake: 香菇是好
Jake: Mushrooms are good.
Tasha: 可以养狼蛛用
Tasha: You can use it to raise tarantulas.
Lucia: sorry狼蛛
Lucia: Sorry, tarantulas?
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 对就是养狼蛛是要垫椰土的
Lucia: Yes, to raise tarantulas, you need coconut soil.
Alice: 你有这爱好
Alice: You have this hobby?
Lucia: 我现在没养
Lucia: I don't have any now.
Lucia: 我以前养过
Lucia: I used to raise them.
Lucia: 但是
Lucia: But...
Jake: 你多大呀
Jake: How old are you?
Lucia: 被我养死了哈哈哈
Lucia: I ended up killing them, hahaha.
Lucia: 呃4只宠物
Lucia: Uh, four pets.
Lucia: 那个岂不是狼蛛不舍他们偷吃养的
Lucia: Wasn't that a tarantula? They didn't steal the food I was raising.
Jake: 啊倒第二
Jake: Ah, second to last.
Jake: 倒数第二名
Jake: Second to last place.
Jake: 第二名吧
Jake: Second place?
Jake: 第二名
Jake: Second place.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice: 准备了一个手链
Alice: I prepared a bracelet.
Alice: 是帝王沙跟绿松石的哦
Alice: It's made of emperor sand and turquoise.
Alice: 朱砂
Alice: Cinnabar.
Alice: 就是古代皇帝批折子用的那个红色的那个颜料就是从这边提取的
Alice: The red pigment that ancient emperors used for official documents is extracted from here.
Alice: 然后绿松石就是蓝绿色
Alice: And turquoise is blue-green.
Alice: 因为有铜跟铁的那些
Alice: Because it contains copper and iron.
Alice: 哎不是铜
Alice: Oh, not copper.
Jake: 啥
Jake: What?
Alice: 铜跟
Alice: Copper and...
Shure:  朱砂
Shure: Cinnabar.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice: 铜跟豆铜跟铁
Alice: Copper and copper and iron.
Alice: 然后他这个会呈现不同的颜色
Alice: And it can show different colors.
Alice: 主要是我觉得朱砂比较辟邪
Alice: Mainly, I think cinnabar wards off evil.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 是这样
Alice: That's it.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 谁电量多来着啊
Jake: Who has the most battery left?
Shure:  啊我我我最老
Shure: Ah, me, me, I'm the oldest.
Jake: 你多少来着
Jake: How much do you have?
Shure:  我是十几
Shure: I'm at ten something.
Shure:  好像
Shure: I think.
Jake: 挺好哎
Jake: That's good!
Jake: 你这啥玩意
Jake: What is this thing?
Shure:  这个是一个乐器
Shure: This is an instrument.
Shure:  它是一个叫做沙球的乐器
Shure: It's called a shaker.
Tasha: 原来这个放到这一直就是你的呀
Tasha: So this has always been yours?
Katrina:  哈哈哈已经被玩过了
Katrina: Hahaha, it's already been played with.
Shure:  已经被大家玩坏了
Shure: Everyone's already worn it out.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  然后他可以这个样子
Shure: And you can use it like this...
Tasha: 然后呢
Tasha: And then?
Shure:  这是他的沙球作用
Shure: This is its sand effect.
Shure:  然后他还可以
Shure: And it can also...
Shure:  就是比如说
Shure: For example...
Shure:  就是它会发出一些碰撞的声音
Shure: It makes some collision sounds.
Shure:  对然后
Shure: Yes, and...
Tasha: AMSR啊哈哈
Tasha: ASMR, haha!
Shure:  最最最酷炫的就是它可以摆起来
Shure: The coolest part is it can be set up.
Tasha: 好酷哈哈
Tasha: So cool, haha!
Shure:  然后配合摆动
Shure: And with the setup...
Shure:  再加上一些
Shure: Add some...
Katrina:  摇滚的东西
Katrina: Rock elements.
Shure:  一些一点点魔法
Shure: A bit of magic.
Shure:  然后就可以打出不一样的节奏型
Shure: Then you can create different rhythms.
Shure:  就比如说像这个样子
Shure: Like this, for example.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh...
Jake: 来一段
Jake: Give us a sample.
Shure:  这是来一段
Shure: Here's a sample.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake: 我以为你叫什么大大节了
Jake: I thought you were calling it a big festival or something.
Lucia: 不应该来点这个才艺表演吗
Lucia: Shouldn’t we have some kind of talent show here?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure:  竹板这么一打呀
Shure: When I start tapping the bamboo clapper,
Shure:  别的咱不夸
Shure: I won’t brag about anything else.
Shure:  咱就夸夸咱那个狗不理包子
Shure: Let’s just praise our Goubuli buns.
Shure:  哈哈这一种赛博快板吧
Shure: Haha, this is some kind of cyber clapper talk, right?
Shure:  可能非洲人的快板就是长这个样子
Shure: Maybe African clapper talk looks like this.
Shure:  哈哈哈这确实好像是一种非洲的乐器
Shure: Haha, it really does seem like some kind of African instrument.
Jake: OK
Shure:  他的学名我忘了叫啥了
Shure: I forgot its scientific name.
Shure:  反正大家都叫它砂锤啊砂球
Shure: Anyway, people call it a sand hammer or sand ball.
Shure:  然后这是一个静音的
Shure: And this one is a silent type.
Shure:  就是它就是这种橡木的
Shure: It's made of oak.
Shure:  然后正常可能会有那种金属的
Shure: Normally, there could be metal ones
Shure:  或者塑料的
Shure: or plastic ones.
Shure:  就是音色是不一样的
Shure: The tones are different.
Shure:  这个就比较不那么吵
Shure: This one is less noisy.
Shure:  然后声音也稍微暖一些
Shure: And the sound is a bit warmer.
Shure:  然后送出一个留一个
Shure: Then give one away and keep one.
Shure:  因为演出还需要用的
Shure: Because we still need it for the show.
Shure:  哈哈哈不能把吃饭家伙事丢了
Shure: Hahaha, can't lose the stuff we use to make a living.
Jake: 你是什么演出要用
Jake: What kind of performance do you need it for?
Shure:  就一些现场的演出也会用到的
Shure: Just some live performances, we'll use it too.
Jake: 哈哈就煮饭啊
Jake: Haha, cooking, right?
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  制造一种氛围音的时候
Shure: When creating some ambient sound.
Lucia: 好像ASMR啊
Lucia: Sounds like ASMR.
Shure:  我再配合这手链给你
Shure: I'll pair it with this bracelet for you.
Katrina:  睡了
Katrina: Fell asleep.
Tasha: 睡了
Tasha: Fell asleep.
Lucia: 困了困了
Lucia: Getting sleepy, getting sleepy.
Alice: 摇酒天赋
Alice: Talent for making cocktails.
Shure:  嗯好哈哈哈好
Shure: Hmm, okay, hahaha, okay.
Katrina:  然后介绍我的吧
Katrina: Then I'll introduce mine.
Katrina:  我就是前前前一段时间去成都玩
Katrina: I went to Chengdu a while ago.
Katrina:  然后去那个玉林路那一些古着店
Katrina: Then went to some vintage shops on Yulin Road.
Katrina:  淘的一些
Katrina: Got some stuff.
Katrina:  呃就是钥匙扣和胸针
Katrina: Uh, like keychains and pins.
Shure:  就是淘宝店淘的新东西是吗
Shure: So you got new stuff from those Taobao shops?
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina:  对淘就是他他那个开店那个店主
Katrina: Yes, got them from the shop owner.
Katrina:  他们是自己设计的
Katrina: They design them themselves.
Katrina:  就是自己是一个设计工作室
Katrina: It's their own design studio.
Katrina:  然后就只有在他
Katrina: And you can only buy them there.
Katrina:  们那里能买到
Katrina: Only at their place.
Katrina:  然后买的是大熊猫的大熊猫
Katrina: Then I bought a giant panda, a giant panda.
Katrina:  这是钥匙扣
Katrina: This is a keychain.
Katrina:  这是一个胸针
Katrina: This is a pin.
Katrina:  就是一个鸟和一个猫
Katrina: It's a bird and a cat.
Katrina:  我也不知道什么意思
Katrina: I don't know what it means.
Katrina:  我只是觉得很可爱
Katrina: I just thought it was cute.
Katrina:  我就买回来送给大家
Katrina: So I bought them back to give to everyone.
Katrina:  好OK
Katrina: Okay, that's it.
Alice: Lucy
Alice: Lucia.
Jake: 好96
Jake: Alright, 96.
Katrina:  嗯抽口的话对这里面有一个marry me
Katrina: Yeah, if you draw one, there's one that says "marry me."
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 不是marry me
Lucia: Not "marry me."
Lucia: 就是我本来是就是有一个小手做的耳钉
Lucia: So, I originally made a small handmade earring.
Lucia: 然后对这个其实很简单
Lucia: And it's actually pretty simple.
Lucia: 就只要买打了孔的珠子
Lucia: You just need to buy some beads with holes.
Lucia: 和这个这个耳针
Lucia: And this earring needle.
Lucia: 然后拿热熔胶把它粘在一起就可以
Lucia: Then just use hot glue to stick them together, and you're done.
Lucia: 对然后但是就是我我自己做完之后
Lucia: Yeah, but after I finished making it,
Lucia: 我觉得这个还那个效果还挺好
Lucia: I thought it turned out pretty well.
Lucia: 所以我做了好几对
Lucia: So I made several pairs.
Lucia: 然后刚好就是这边要给大家
Lucia: And it just so happened that here we needed to
Lucia: 就是给大家准备礼物
Lucia: Prepare gifts for everyone.
Lucia: 我就准备了一个
Lucia: So I prepared one.
Lucia: 感觉是自己的手做的话会比较有意义
Lucia: I feel like handmade gifts have more meaning.
Lucia: 但是为什么我又去买了一个抽屉呢
Lucia: But why did I buy a drawer?
Lucia: 因为我发现这个盒子有点大
Lucia: Because I found the box a bit big.
Lucia: 当我把它放到这盒子里面的时候
Lucia: When I put them in the box,
Lucia: 他们俩显得非常的孤单
Lucia: They looked very lonely.
Lucia: 然后我为了增加开盒的时候的气势
Lucia: So, to make the box opening more impressive,
Lucia: 我就又去买了一个抽壳放在里面
Lucia: I bought another drawer to put inside.
Lucia: 然后但这样一放
Lucia: And then just place it like this.
Lucia: 就会完全挡住他们两个
Lucia: it will completely block the two of them.
Lucia: 所以就是对
Lucia: So, yes,
Lucia: 于是这个礼物
Lucia: this gift
Lucia: 就变成了一个复合装饰的样子
Lucia: turns into a kind of composite decoration.
Lucia: 然后这个就很就是这个
Lucia: And this is really, like,
Lucia: 我觉得还蛮好看的
Lucia: I think it looks pretty nice.
Lucia: 因为它是那种丝绒的料
Lucia: Because it's made of velvet material,
Lucia: 就是穿很多裙子都可以搭配
Lucia: it can match with a lot of dresses.
Lucia: 但是男孩子的话就不考虑了
Lucia: But for boys, not really.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  行了
Shure: Alright.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Shure:  你怎么能定定义我
Shure: How can you define me like that?
Lucia: 对不起对不起我错了啊
Lucia: I'm sorry, I'm sorry. I was wrong.
Shure:  我就是你看正好两个嘛
Shure: See, there are exactly two of them.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Lucia: 没有想到这一次
Lucia: I didn't expect this time...
Lucia: 那那那说明你也是可以试用的
Lucia: So, that means you can try it too.
Lucia: 那大家挑选起来就没有顾虑
Lucia: That way, everyone can pick without worry.
Alice: 对呵
Alice: Yeah.
Shure:  好话都
Shure: Well, you said everything.
Shure:  让你说完了
Shure: You finished all the good words.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Okay
Jake: 那路亚开始
Jake: Then let's start the lure.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This
Jake: 这怎么挑的
Jake: How did you choose this?
Lucia: 我以为是盲挑来着
Lucia: I thought it was a blind pick.
Jake: 咱盲挑
Jake: Let's do a blind pick.
Lucia: 感觉都很有特色的样子
Lucia: They all seem very unique.
Shure:  先说一句好话
Shure: First, say something nice.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina:  憋出来了
Katrina: Finally said it.
Jake: 那咱要不盲挑也可以要不
Jake: So we could do a blind pick, or we could...
Lucia: 我我我摇个骰子吧
Lucia: I'll roll a dice then.
Lucia: 那就要不
Lucia: So, how about...
Shure:  行
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 嗯可以抽到我自己怎么办
Lucia: Hmm, what if I draw myself?
Katrina:  一二
Katrina: One, two
Alice: 再来一轮
Alice: Let's do another round.
Katrina:  4
Katrina: Four
Shure:  1234 对咱们
Shure: One, two, three, four, right, us
Lucia: 对咱们
Lucia: Right, us.
Lucia: 咱们的群呢
Lucia: Our group, right?
Lucia: 我放到我就在咱们群里摇好了
Lucia: I'll roll it in our group.
Shure:  公平公正公开
Shure: Fair, just, and open.
Shure:  sorry
Shure: Sorry.
Katrina:  特别可爱是不是
Katrina: It's super cute, isn't it?
Jake: 直播摇骰子
Jake: Live dice rolling.
Lucia: 2 我结果大家能看得到吗
Lucia: Two, can everyone see the result?
Lucia: 发了一个
Lucia: Sent one.
Tasha: 看到了
Tasha: I see it.
Alice: 二
Alice: Two
Lucia: 二
Lucia: Two
Alice: 谁是2
Alice: Who is number 2?
Lucia: 按介绍说明
Lucia: According to the instructions...
Alice: 我是2
Alice: I'm number 2.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah
Lucia: 谢谢可馨
Lucia: Thank you, Kexin.
Lucia: 啊这个包装也好好看
Lucia: Ah, this packaging is so pretty.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 骰子是在表情里吗
Jake: 好
Jake: Yes
Katrina:  表情里
Katrina: In the emojis
Jake: 那我们第二
Jake: Then let's go with the second one
Jake: 第二名来挑
Jake: The second place picks
Jake: 倒数第二名来挑
Jake: The second to last picks
Shure:  哈哈你挑的你都都不那什么了
Shure: Haha, you pick and you don't even say anything
Shure:  客套话都不说直接闪了
Shure: Skipping the pleasantries and just leaving
Katrina:  我
Katrina: Me
Katrina:  哈哈迫不及待啊
Katrina: Haha, can't wait
Katrina:  会直接搜筛子
Katrina: Just search for dice
Jake: 这是真骰子 假筛骰子每次都能摇6
Shure:  哎你这是固定三的
Shure: Hey, yours is fixed at 3
Katrina:  真假
Katrina: Really?
Katrina:  什么叫固定3
Katrina: What's fixed at 3?
Jake: 那再再忍一下你自己
Jake: Then hold on and try yourself
Shure:  一二哎
Shure: One, two, hey
Shure:  不是3是我  3是我
Shure: It's not 3, it's me. 3 is me
Jake: 等一下我再再再摇一下看是固定的吗
Jake: Wait, let me roll again to see if it's fixed
Alice: 不是吧不是
Alice: No way, it's not
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: It's not, it's not
Jake: OK那那行那行
Jake: OK, then it's fine
Katrina:  还是3
Katrina: Still 3
Lucia: 还是3
Lucia: Still 3
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey
Shure:  你没有表这个表情吗
Shure: Don't you have this emoji?
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh
Jake: 摇出一个亿
Lucia: 摇出一个亿
Katrina:  给我自己
Katrina: For myself
Shure:  那就3吧
Shure: Then it's 3
Jake: 就三三好
Jake: Just 3 is fine
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh
Katrina:  哈哈哈每天晚上你会听到我在房间
Katrina: Haha, every night you will hear me in my room
Shure:  没事我在你楼下
Shure: No worries, I'm downstairs
Jake: 好那到你摇吧
Jake: Alright, now it's your turn to roll
Jake: 你倒啊
Jake: You roll
Shure:  我我摇吧还是
Shure: I'll roll then
Jake: 你客套话呢
Jake: Where's your politeness?
Shure:  客套话就是
Shure: Polite words are just
Katrina:  谢谢大家
Katrina: Thank you, everyone.
Shure:  大家每个都非常的棒
Shure: Everyone did really great.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: And then,
Shure:  让我实在难以割舍
Shure: It's really hard for me to choose.
Shure:  选哪个割舍其他的
Shure: Which one to keep and which to let go.
Shure:  都是一种
Shure: It's all a kind of
Katrina:  演上了
Katrina: Drama time.
Shure:  我是几 四
Shure: Am I number four?
Shure:  1234 呀
Shure: One, two, three, four, right?
Katrina:  呀
Katrina: Right.
Katrina:  这么可爱的送给你
Katrina: Giving this cute one to you.
Shure:  哪有
Shure: No way.
Katrina:  送给你哈哈送给你
Katrina: Giving it to you, haha, giving it to you.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 达成了交换
Lucia: Exchange completed.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake: 那我们
Jake: So we...
Shure:  剩下二位就变成交换了
Shure: The remaining two will exchange.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice: 你得给我
Alice: You have to give me...
Lucia: 哦  对 你们只能交换了
Lucia: Oh, right, you can only exchange now.
Tasha: 我知道
Tasha: I know.
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
Shure:  完了
Shure: Done.
Shure:  没抽到洋鼓很可惜
Shure: It's a pity I didn't get a drum.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 那就收拾收拾准备出发
Jake: Let's pack up and get ready to go.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  你这个要导数据吗
Katrina: Do you need to export this data?
Jake: 要
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  你之前要倒一会啊
Katrina: You need to back it up first, right?
Tasha: 这钱我也不知道怎么啊
Tasha: I don't know what to do with this money.
Tasha: 就是好看
Tasha: It just looks nice.
Shure:  卡掉
Shure: Cut it off.
Jake: 呃先先带回带回去
Jake: Uh, first take it back, take it back.
Jake: 然后带到一楼
Jake: Then take it to the first floor.
Jake: 放到那个
Jake: Put it there...
Tasha: 你可以把它
Tasha: You can put it...
Jake: 盒里边
Jake: Inside the box.
Tasha: 那个是书法课上面老师
Tasha: That was from the calligraphy class teacher.
Tasha: 呃统一买的
Tasha: Uh, it was bought uniformly.
Lucia: 哦可以好奇一下写的什么
Lucia: Oh, can I be curious about what it's written?
Alice: 笑口常开
Alice: "Smile often."
Lucia: 哇好好看啊
Lucia: Wow, it looks so nice.
Lucia: 写的好好
Lucia: It's written so well.
Alice: 回眸
Alice: "Looking back."
Jake: 啊谁写的
Jake: Ah, who wrote it?
Jake: 你写的哦
Jake: You wrote it?
Lucia: 微微写的
Lucia: Tasha wrote it.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: It's so pretty.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Shure:  是不是有点太短了
Shure: Isn't it a bit too short?
Alice: 也差不多
Alice: It's about right.
Jake: 好看
Jake: It looks good.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 就大家把礼物放到自己房间
Jake: So everyone put their gifts in their own rooms.
Jake: 然后下去再一起结束就结束了
Jake: Then we'll go downstairs together and finish up.
Katrina:  放到自己的房间
Katrina: Put in your own room.
Alice: 是上一年
Alice: It was last year.
Alice: 去年冬天写的
Alice: I wrote it last winter.
Tasha: 对哎我
Tasha: Yeah, I...
Jake: 我跳舞了
Jake: I danced.
Alice: 今年是甲醛
Alice: This year it's formaldehyde.
Jake: 在外面跳舞回眸
Jake: Dancing outside, looking back.
Shure:  回眸
Shure: Looking back.
Jake: 你们得在外面跳舞回眸
Jake: You guys need to dance outside and look back.
Jake: 然后拍拍照
Jake: Then take photos.
Jake: 拍完照最后一天放PPT
Jake: After the photos, we'll show the PPT on the last day.
Alice: 我念对念惯了
Alice: I'm used to reciting it right.
Shure:  这样呢应该是
Shure: It should be like this.
Jake: 对就是pick lick是跳舞对吧
Jake: Yeah, just like "pick lick" is dancing, right?
Jake: 准备好防晒准备好
Jake: Get ready with sunscreen, get prepared.
Shure:  玩吧
Shure: Let's play.
Jake: 呃拍拍照准备最后一天放PPT准备好
Jake: Uh, take photos, be ready to show the PPT on the last day, get prepared.
Jake: 对就是手机拍拍照
Jake: Yeah, just take photos with your phone.
Lucia: 为什么我会砸到我自己的手
Lucia: Why did I hit my own hand?
Shure:  因为它长
Shure: Because it's long.
Shure:  哦不不不就是夹的
Shure: Oh no no no, just clip it.
Jake: 呃对OK
Jake: Uh, right, OK.
Jake: 然后准备买肉
Jake: Then let's get ready to buy meat.
Lucia: 不行我还是会砸到自己的手
Lucia: No way, I'll still hit my own hand.
Jake: 晚上还有烤串
Jake: We'll have skewers tonight.
Jake: BBQ晚上烤串加甜点
Jake: BBQ tonight with skewers and desserts.
Tasha: 下午是要出去吗
Tasha: Are we going out this afternoon?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Katrina:  晚上还有披萨
Katrina: There's pizza tonight.
Katrina:  两个够了不用再点
Katrina: Two are enough, no need to order more.
Jake: 这下午茶是披萨
Jake: This afternoon's snack is pizza.
Jake: 可能在外边你们走累了吃俩披萨
Jake: Maybe if you get tired outside, you can eat two pizzas.
Katrina:  哦你说让披萨带出去
Katrina: Oh, you mean take the pizza out?
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Yes, okay?
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Sure.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mhm.
Katrina:  我得换件衣服
Katrina: I need to change clothes.
Katrina:  我得装这个东西没口袋
Katrina: I need to carry this thing, no pockets.
Katrina:  装裤子
Katrina: I'll wear pants.
Shure:  确实很治愈
Shure: It's really healing.
Shure:  来杨老板坐这
Shure: Come on Jake, sit here.
Shure:  我给你治愈一下
Shure: I'll heal you a bit.
Shure:  哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh ouch ouch.
Lucia: 给你听个现场的鲜花
Lucia: Let me play you some live flowers.
Jake: 环绕声是吧
Jake: Surround sound, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  一般拿个颂锅先duang
Shure: Usually you take a singing bowl and go "duang".
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 还是双摄
Lucia: Double camera.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 挺好水平挺高
Jake: Pretty good, high level.
Jake: 自带混响
Jake: Built-in reverb.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mhm.
Lucia: 哈哈这视频可以录吗
Lucia: Haha, can we record this video?
Lucia: 晚上睡觉的时候就用来助眠用
Lucia: Use it to help sleep at night.
Jake: 可以你这卖钱吗
Jake: Can you sell it?
Jake: 你要不你录一段
Jake: How about you record a segment?
Jake: 卖钱
Jake: And sell it.
Lucia: 你开一个
Lucia: You start one.
Jake: 卖多少钱
Jake: How much are you selling this for?
Lucia: AMSR频道
Lucia: ASMR channel
Jake: 这个卖多少钱
Jake: How much is this selling for?
Shure:  不知道
Shure: No idea.
Jake: 你这个掉了
Jake: You dropped this.
Shure:  我这个可以摘了
Shure: I can take this off.
Shure:  应该
Shure: I think.
Jake: 行啊
Jake: Sure.
Shure:  是要导数据的是吧
Shure: We need to export the data, right?
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice: 现在就导吗
Alice: Export it now?
Jake: 对他们把东西放回房间
Jake: Yeah, they need to put the stuff back in the room.
Jake: 然后把眼镜给解决
Jake: Then we need to take care of the glasses.
Jake: 然后再结束
Jake: Then we can finish up.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 放回去
Jake: Put it back.
Jake: 然后再结束
Jake: Then we finish up.
Jake: 再都
Jake: Then all...
Shure:  忘拿了
Shure: I almost forgot to take it.
Shure:  差点
Shure: Almost.
Jake: 不是放回去到下面一起结束这么回事
Jake: No, you put it back and then we'll finish everything together.
Shure:  好OK
Shure: Okay, got it.
Lucia: 哎我这怎么又加载不出来了
Lucia: Oh no, why is it not loading again?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 退出再进一些啊
Lucia: Try exiting and re-entering.
Lucia: 正常了太好了
Lucia: It's working now, great.
Lucia: 看看什么时候停止呢
Lucia: Let's see when it stops.
Shure:  再见杨老板
Shure: Goodbye, Jake.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake: 子堂开工
Jake: Let's get to work.
Katrina:  哎真好
Katrina: Oh, that's great.
Jake: 嗯开工
Jake: Yeah, let's get to work.
Jake: 对开工
Jake: Yes, get to work.
Shure:  然后我们
Shure: And then we...
Shure:  我们停掉
Shure: We stop.
Katrina:  是我的
Katrina: That's mine.
Jake: 呃停OK
Jake: Uh, stop, okay.
Jake: 行停掉
Jake: Alright, stop it.
Jake: 停掉停掉
Jake: Stop it, stop it.
Alice: 停掉了
Alice: It's stopped.
Jake: 停掉然后
Jake: Stop it, and then...
Jake: 哎让他等我们倒吧
Jake: Hey, let him wait for us to finish.